I think with casino royale we wanted to
change the directions the franchise and
we've been trying to do that and I think
this film really culminates it and
achieving that goal it's Daniels really
come into his own and the way it's been
received by the public's been fantastic
it's not it's unusual for director to
come on to a movie and fight and be
working with a leading actor who knows
the part he's playing better than you do
and in many ways the good thing is he's
established he's done the hard work you
know and I keep saying the same thing
which is there's no way we could have
made this movie without the amazing work
martin campbell did on casino royale
because that was a much more in many
ways much more difficult step to make
totally new bond removing pastiche
completely no q no Moneypenny no
self-referential humor I don't think we
go for gag type do you wear it's a bit
ironic bit black dark humor and and
that's the part that's what market works
the best I think there have been less
producers in the Bond franchise then
there have been people playing bond
there's only ever been for producers of
bond movies and and and you feel you
feel that it's a family business and you
know what are the chances that the
coincidence that one of the great and
most famous producers of all time cubby
broccoli should have two children who
are born producers but it is true and
saving their presence and they they make
it feel possible for you to make
something that is part of their world
and yet somehow also your own Roger is
one of the greats I mean I think that's
not that's not an opinion as a fact and
he is very detail-oriented he wants a
lot of prep which we needed on this
movie he's incredible worker he's very
quiet and focused on set I think the big
thing for him was and for all of us
really well for me included is that you
know my normal way of working with Roger
one or possibly two cameras and one crew
but on a bomb movie or the head of a
huge department if you're the
cinematographer you have nope you know
you have a first unit you're often
shooting on upwards of six seven eight
cameras depending on what the scene is
what the stunts are you a second unit
got a splinter unit you've got a
miniature unit you're working in tana
with visual effects special effects and
departments that suddenly don't exist on
smaller movies so for him it was a
leadership thing too he had to be
prepared to be the leader of that
department you know and as did I and I
think that you know it was very much it
was very important that we had the
embryo of the film in our head the whole
time but because you can lose that very
quickly when you're being pulled in all
directions I wanted to return perhaps to
some of the more flamboyant theatrical
Bond villains of the early years the
doctor knows and the gold fingers and
the rows of clubs and and also I so one
of the things I i said to him very early
on was you you have to want to have some
fun with it because you know and
actually was some of his agent said to
me that she just did telling me he's to
have some fun you know and and he did
there's mischief and you know but he
himself as a person is immense fun and
it is never far from laughter you know
and I think it was just unlocking that
part of him but it wasn't difficult you
know and he was so full of ideas and so
much of what you say on screen has come
from him but you know we tried as much
as possible and I think this is the key
with all locations it to find locations
that mirror the story of the central
character in this case bond and and
ultimately you know there's a great
danger to showing locations simply for
the eye candy and and not because they
mean anything or they add anything to
the story and I felt that what we needed
at the beginning which was Istanbul was
was you know bustling and lively and
full of color and warmth and things that
then become absent from the film when
bond effectively dies when he comes back
it's a very monochromatic world it's
it's very empty he comes back
effectively when he comes back from his
death as it were he finds everything
changed you know am isn't giving the
orders anymore mi6's and the different
q is a young man and he bond is the
dinosaur bond is the past really and the
movie is about whether he is the past or
the future you know and because they
told me he had two more movies he had to
be the future so